[Music]
hello there
season five of chapter one of fortnite
has been hinted at
extensively this season in a world
colliding event
but this has taken to a whole new level
when fortnite's twitter
account was seemingly hacked by one of
the characters coming to the game
the strangest thing is those tweets were
quickly deleted
removing them from history but don't
worry i took screenshots to allow us to
break down their meaning
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes use
code adamaru to support this content
and let's look at masks mysteries cherry
blossom
and incoming mayhem
over a period of four hours eight tweets
were sent from the fortnite twitter
account
in which vi the new character is
attempting to contact drift
the character from chapter one season
five drift is the first character we
know to have traveled from
our world the real world a graffiti
artist
taken from the californian desert back
when the visitors rocket cracked space
and time at the end of season four
rifts began to appear dragging other
worlds to the island
like a golf course an entire desert and
a viking ship
remember that one for later but these
anomalies went in both directions
here on earth llamas began to appear in
london and other parts of europe
and the der burger's head appeared in
north america a very real
item in a very real location people
swarmed there to see the attraction
but one man got closer than all the
others
drift before anyone noticed him he used
the opportunity
to tag the burger before he knew it
though drift as well as that burger
were ripped back through time and space
and back to the fortnite island
back in chapter one we had loading
screens linked to seasonal plots
those days were really good when drift
arrived on the island
he was quickly befriended by bright
bomber and her crew
over the following weeks of the season
drift began to understand the island and
learn to live with his new friends and
allies
this was the same season which
introduced us to kevin the cube and the
dark skinned variants
and also the enforcers there's a lot to
unpack so let's reframe this with the
hacked tweets
the second communication reads i know
you don't know who i am
but the fox clan is in trouble we need
you the fox clan as far as i know has
never been referenced in fortnite before
and this tweet confirms that faction yet
another to add to the seven
and the imagined order we also now know
drift is still being watched
years later the next tweet backs this up
we always thought we were the trackers
but something is tracking
us down now something old
something bad they got everyone i barely
escaped
i'm the only one left who could they be
well there is something we've been
waiting to return for years
the enforcers the secret road trip skin
from season five of chapter one
they made a massive impact on arrival
rifting to the island
and judging by the faces of the group
these guys
were not good news for our heroes we all
prepared for the nexus and the cube to
be somehow linked to the enforcers
but well yeah you know nothing happened
at all at that point
i've tried many times to predict their
return even suggesting the io commandos
could be from the same force
but now could those enforcers return
right in front of our eyes by these
hacked tweets
the tweet reads they got everyone not he
got everyone not she got everyone so
unless this person is non-binary
they are a collective of multiple
members
just like the enforcers
let's keep going with this look at the
next tweet it's packed with law
whoever gave you that foxclan mask made
you the target
wow as a man who hides behind a pink and
white mask
this is good to see so who gave him the
mask
the first time we saw the fox mask which
is fundamentally the same as a kitteny
mask
or kitsune if you prefer it to be more
westernized in japanese folklore
this was the first spray tag drift
painted in the californian desert
so we can surmise right away that either
drift had the mask
all along in the real world or his spray
tag idea was made into a mask for him by
someone
in the fortnite world if you watched my
previous video about the identity of
agent jones's boss
you'll know where i'm going with this
over the course of season 5 chapter 1
drift evolved from a graffiti artist
wearing a mask
which we all should do in the world
right now and became a fully super
powered individual
the final design is obviously based on
his artwork and as we know drift arrived
without
any of his final form gear he acquired
it
whilst he was here the first time he
donned the mask was at a pool party
which means the person who gave him that
mask
is likely in this image my guess is the
bright bomber
as their relationship grew over that
season although judging by the tree
carving in chapter 2
bibi and drift aren't as in love as they
once were
rip the dream the next tweet reads if we
don't work together
team up they'll come for you next they
are closing
in so now we know that a new foxclan
member is coming to fortnite
right now we don't know if vi is a drift
snapshot or someone completely unique or
could be linked to the japanese folklore
it's interesting that this skin is
locked behind the fortnite crew pay wall
but if it's linked to narrative
count me in take my money epic games but
anyway you know me i needed to look past
the obvious and begin to
look out for other skins akin to drift
during season x
you know the season where the world is
destabilizing fast
but don't worry in this season we
unlocked the female variant of drift in
the form of
catalyst it's widely speculated that
this is another drift snapshot
rifted from a dimension in which drift
was born female
and also we have the live animal back
bling kitsune
which is the word for a fox in japanese
kid's nay or should i say kitsune
kitsune is also linked to a story of
paranormal spirits
that can shapeshift some people believe
these to be evil vengeful spirits
and others proclaim these to be good
beings
what you may not realize is how often
you see them
for example sonic the hedgehog his best
mate miles tales per hour
he's a kitsune he has two tails part of
the myth
is that they can grow up to nine tails
anyone thinking of the pokemon right now
now we know why it's called nine tails
but when to compound all this
the official black bling is the japanese
shrine cut into two
making it adjacent f's standing for fox
it's all starting to link together the
law is coming
[Music]
so i've left my best theory for last so
people who don't stick around
don't get the goodness in their eye
holes i began to look at evil spirits in
japanese mythology
and the yokai i realized we've already
got one in the game right now
condor here's the audio log
reality log 42 the next recruit goes by
condor i finally got him to stop
standing in the rain monologuing about
cherry blossoms or whatever that was
according to local legend he's a
vengeful
spirit given to the emperor's family
centuries ago and passed down since
they say he'll grant any wish for
revenge
no matter how dark or terrible so
let's all be very careful what we wish
for
condor is an evil entity of revenge
according to the myth
he is always present beside the ruler of
each japanese province
like an evil god of war waiting to
strike the reference to cherry blossom
confirms condor is of japanese descent
and so is the fox clan could the clues
already be here
is the war between condor and drift as
extra confirmation about condor his room
at the haven contains lots of japanese
cultural references
like bonsai tree a real tree but a teeny
tiny version
he also has swords here and some sake
the audio file also references the
cherry blossom tree
a quintessential japanese tree and can
you remember the last time we saw one in
fortnite
hell yeah lucky landing i kind of always
thought it was chinese so i feel like a
fool right now but i'm sorry japanese
people
it's cool all the same remember when we
said at the very beginning that season
five of chapter one
is returning check this look where
condor is right now
in game he's at misty meadows and look
where the original lucky landing is in
chapter one
almost exactly in the same position it's
likely in the next update both realities
will converge
bringing the return of the foxclan in
lucky landing and the spirit of
vengeance with
condor a battle will ensue very soon
which side will win
the final tweet reads i need to wipe my
tracks but i hope you got this
transmission
if you did i'll see you soon i hope
connection terminated in eight tweets
fortnite added more lore and story than
most seasons combined
with returning characters story beats
locations and by the looks of it
she's a narrative driven character i
have a few more theories about the fade
skin remember that
which i won't go into right now but did
you know before he was renamed vade
he was known as dark drift and he
doesn't evolve into a kitsune
he evolves into an oni interesting isn't
it
we've gone down way too many rabbit
holes today for one video maybe a five
night at freddy crossover theory coming
soon
you never know on screen now are more
legends who kindly brought code adamarro
in the store
i truly appreciate you thank you for
letting me do this i'm calling it a job
i'll be back in my dms later today
replying to you guys
thanks again i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time